floating space sex pissed off
necromancers
and delicious delicious fungus here
i brought you some fungus
thanks hbo has just released episodes
six and seven of raised by wolves and
we've got tons of new theories and
details to discuss
including where these voices might be
coming from what's going on with marcus
and his big revelation that he is the
prophet but before we begin
be a good mithraic and make sure you've
liked and subscribe as i'll be breaking
down
every episode of the season we're back
on earth or at least a
archived memory of earth where with
mother who tells her creator campion
sturgis
that something doesn't feel right
something's wrong
there's a feeling inside me
everything hurts she's experiencing
heartache leaving her creator who she
loves these emotions
androids shouldn't be feeling and mother
is watching this event
over and over again obsessed even
imagining herself
kissing her creator on the outskirts of
camp sue and marcus watch paul debating
about whether they should tell him the
truth about his parentage a rift has
formed over the last few episodes
between sue and marcus particularly
around marcus's newfound role as head of
the mathrae this rift will split even
further when marcus ends up using
paul as a pawn in his plan to destroy
mother
risking his own son's life or his goal
something
sue doesn't take kindly to veda plays
with a doll a doll she tells tempest
tally taught her how to make tally's the
first generation girl who's been
haunting some of the characters
throughout the last few episodes
paul found a similar doll right before
he fell down the hole tempus asks mother
because she's an android if she wishes
she had nightmares
i do not wish for things i'm not one who
wants i'm one who serves
which we know is [ __ ] mother dreams
of being with her creator hell there's
a whole weird floating sex scene paul in
champion's relationship which seemed to
be great a few episodes ago
quickly deteriorates as their beliefs
drift further from one another
paul believes only humans have souls
while campion believes everyone does
even
mother father and the trees champion's
envy of paul is shown on full display
when paul is able to complete the stick
puzzle in 20 seconds while it took
champion 23 minutes there's a backstory
between lucius and marcus about lucius's
father
lucius's father let an atheist girl they
captured live but she ended blowing
herself
up and killing half the platoon so
marcus executed him it's unclear how
this story will play out in future
episodes but it's not the first time
this event has been addressed something
tells me there's more to this story and
when marcus is revealed to
not be who he says he is it could bite
him in the ass marcus finds out that
mother has been accessing the sim for
long periods at a time
when she's plugged in she can't sense
movement
she can't see she can't hear
she's vulnerable he plans to trap her
while she's logged in
and then destroy her and this whole
episode centers around traps
the mithraic trapping mother paul
trapping the creatures
and later marcus using his son to trap a
mother campion punches paul when he
finds out the fungus bait they collected
will be used in his traps to capture
creatures
i'm glad you two are becoming friends so
that was a [ __ ] lie the whole
point of the fungus in the first place
was for campion to provide an
alternative source of sustenance rather
than
killing and eating those creatures he's
brought into mother where he won't
apologize for hitting paul
i did the violence thing and i'll do
violence again if i have to no you will
not you are a pacifist they're really
turning champion into an annoying
petulant
child contrasting him to paul in almost
every way but what the show is really
doing
is showing how humanity is doomed to
continue this cycle of conflict
over and over again no matter how hard
you work to keep them safe mother in the
end
who will always destroy themselves over
and over and over again
mother obsesses with a picture someone
drew in tally's style on the wall
so obsessed in fact that she runs her
fingers across it so much that it begins
to smudge
the two figures here are mother and the
creator kissing
father sees it too so we know it's not
just in her mind
it's uncertain what these drawings
around it are perhaps it's wreckage from
the lander they used to travel to kepler
but whoever drew this new mother was
having these memories
mother ventures back to the sim in
search of answers meanwhile the mithraic
prepare their trap
marcus has enlisted otho and even said
of his plan works he'll be pardoned
otho is tempus rapist so expect that
he'll get pardoned or escape
somehow in upcoming episodes mother
asked the sim if anyone has accessed it
since the crash and yes
someone has when asked if this user was
android or
human the sim responds unknown and when
asked if this user is currently
in the simulation there's no answer the
first theory here one that mother states
is that it's a virus the same virus may
have infected the humans on their
journey to kepler while they were in
stasis hence why multiple people hear
voices but that wouldn't explain why
campion hears them too
the second theory is that it's a rogue
ai perhaps controlled by the
consciousness of campion sturgis
after all the sim said it didn't know if
the user was human or android what if it
were
something else we've also seen this
thing only known as the host who lives
on the planet
it could be alien or perhaps a fail-safe
android that was sent to the planet
before mother and father arrived by
campion normally i wouldn't suggest
alien but the fact we saw this giant
polyhedron a few episodes ago
which ambrose said confirmed the
presence of a once ancient civilization
and that the planet has other alien
creatures on it we can't leave this
theory off the table
in the sim mother finds a version of
champion sturgis he says he's been alone
for so long he's almost given up hope
leading me to believe this vision is
controlled by the hermit-like entity we
saw crawling around
last episode i think one of the more
interesting lines comes here
you are human yes but i'm anything
the sim didn't pick up another human so
it must mean
something different right perhaps he's
human in some ways but not in
others we also find out here mother's
real want to be with her creator not the
protection of her children
tell me what you want i
want you one of the crazy things about
this sim sequence and no
i don't mean the floating sex is that
mother seems to experience an
inception-like sim experience within a
sim experience culminating in a pool of
android blood filling the room
foreshadowing her almost death at the
end of the episode the plan to take down
mother goes terribly wrong as her
necromorphic powers prove too strong for
the mithraic meanwhile sue goes against
marcus's orders and rescues paul while
veda sees a vision of mother's drawing
turn
black is this the alien creature that's
able to create visions or is there
another necromancer on the planet i
believe it was champion who said in one
of the earlier episodes that
necromancers have the ability to make
you see things
i also find it strange that these
streams of light around the photo look
similar to the ones surrounding campion
in the sim
father is neutralized in the attack
before mother comes to save the day
it's here that paul is used by marcus to
go back to the camp and steal mother's
eyes without them she's powerless sue is
against this but marcus says you gotta
stop doubting him
start believing in him more prophetic
semantics
paul is successful at obtaining the eyes
and when mother chases after him she's
cut down by
marcus successfully putting methric in
control of the children when marcus is
about to finish mother for good a voice
speaks to him to let her live
is it saul or is it something else we do
know that if sturgis is behind the voice
and
loves mother he'd want her to live sue
is still pissed at marcus for using paul
you used paul you're no better than the
[ __ ]
that sent you to the front when you were
12 years old this line also acts as a
reminder of marcus or should i say
caleb's origin he was a child soldier
after being orphaned his orphan
background comes into play at the end of
the episode when he tells sue that he is
the prophet
but we'll get into that in a bit sue
wants marcus to grab paul
and father and take the lander to the
tropical zone to start a new life
together
she is still committed to a world
without believers
these people destroyed the earth
if we keep this up we're not survivors
we're traitors marcus is told to destroy
mother but she's the most powerful
weapon on the planet and they need her
for protection
if he can reprogram her they could use
her to their advantage
marcus's visions continue like the
scalpel which he saw in episode 5 that
he used to stab
sue perhaps foreshadowing his betrayal
of her marcus visits mother who they've
tied up like one of the creatures she
can sense he's not like the other
mythric
you changed your face
did you change her name with it this is
likely why she let him live
all the way back in episode 1 when she
could have easily zapped him
she even caresses his face before
knocking him out of the lander
marcus really wants to know why she kept
going back to the sim what would an
android want with it but mother isn't
saying anything and i don't know about
you guys but this
almost kiss freaked me out it's just so
weird and either
points at marcus going insane or
something else at play here the mathiak
tried to bring back a sense of normalcy
for the children they're given new
pendants bring back prayer
and father is reprogrammed to be a
service droid tempus however is
not happy after all it was a mithraic
who raped her she's keeping her secret
that she's with child from them but it's
only a matter of time before that comes
out
champion is locked away from the others
because he is considered impure
he'll only be allowed out if he agrees
to be baptized
paul also goes back to creating his
mithraic city just like he did in the
sim justina mentions that he could be
the prophet
saying perhaps the boy foretold to
unlock the mysteries
is not an orphan after all but paul is
technically an orphan or at least
was his real parents were killed campion
finds one of tally's dolls attached to
some sort of bone shank a voice tells
him to kill himself so they can quote
all be together something or someone is
wanting him to be reunited with his dead
siblings
whoever this is also has this ability to
move these carbos almost telepathically
and the only other entity we know so far
who can move objects are
necromancers marcus has another terrible
one-on-one with mother who gets inside
his head saying he's not fit to raise
paul since he himself is a lost boy
and i guess she's kind of right since as
soon as he leaves he pushes paul
over this is all part of marcus's
descent into madness he's
definitely not the marcus we've seen
from episode one to five
something has really taken over him and
it's changing the way he acts
he'll later lash out at sue the person
he loves most saying
you know you would not be alive if it
wasn't for me when he's alone he sees
visions of his former self and at the
end of the episode he'll even face off
against that vision campion agrees to be
baptized but declines at the last minute
when he finds out the mithriak have used
the headstones of his siblings to
construct their new church
you can even make out the spir for his
sister spira here
and check out this look from sue when
champion decides not to go through with
the baptism
i think this is foreshadowing some major
shifts in whose side is on whose
paul continues to work on his mithra
city when he finds his mouse who had
previously fallen down a hole he
believes
seoul brought him back but it makes me
question whether things that fall down
the hole
are truly gone for good tally apparently
fell down there and now we're seeing her
haunt
campion marcus ends up taking mother to
be dropped down the hole
and destroyed tempest even follows after
him but is slowed down by pursuing
creatures
marcus once again hears a voice call out
to let mother live
but when that doesn't seem to work a
vision of his former self
caleb appears to stop him as we'll find
out this is all in marcus's head
someone or something is manipulating his
mind as we pull away to the wide shot
the vision has vanished and marcus has
cut himself in the final scene he'll
drop his scalpel but it turns into
a knife when he arrives back all
bloodied sue tells him that she has the
lander ready to go but he says they're
not going anywhere the prophecy about
the orphan boy and the empty land
isn't about paul it's about him but who
told him this
at this point there's no evidence that
saul exists but we do know there is this
entity that is able to whisper in
people's minds i'm thinking that whoever
it is
is lying to marcus and just using him
just like this
supposed voice of saul spoke to otho and
once he was done with him
never spoke to him again if you haven't
seen my episode 4-5 breakdown i suggest
giving that a watch as i go into more
detail on what i think this voice is
and we didn't really get a lot of new
clues in episodes 6 and 7 to really
change that theory i'm really hoping the
next few episodes pick up the pace a
little and start giving us some more
answers but until then i'll just have to
believe
this show can pull through oh god these
puns thanks for watching everyone please
make sure to like and subscribe and if
you haven't followed me on twitter or
instagram you can find me at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you